ｶｼｬｶｼｬｶｼｬｶｼｬ（カメラの音）
ちょっとフラッシュやめてもらっていいすか？
ﾌｯ（謎の声
今日は！はじめしゃちょーです
今日はですねこちら富山県の
僕の地元のサッカーチームのカターレ富山さんの
試合の会場に今来ております
今日は僕何をしようかと言いますと
カターレ富山さんの試合の入場
ピッチに入場する時があるんですけども
そのタイミングで僕が紛れ込んで！
ビッチに行ってみようと思います
一応ちゃんとカターレ富山さんのユニフォームを着ていくんで！
はたしてみんなにばれずにカターレ富山さんのチームに紛れ込んで
入場できるのかどうかをﾁｮｯﾄやってみようと思います！
フラッシュやめてもらっていいすか！ﾁｮｯﾄフラッシュやめてもらっていいすか！
声を合わせて行きましょう!（ナレーション）
カタール！
ｳｪｰｰｰｰｰｰｰ
ﾍｪｪｪｪｪｪ！
選手入場です！
（恐怖）
ｷｴｱｧｧｧｧ！！！！！
ｷｬｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!!（恐怖の悲鳴）
ｳﾜｱｱｧｧｧｧ!!（恐怖）
みんな！
ぼくのの地元はどこか知ってますか？
静岡じゃないＺＯ★
いま静岡に住んでるんですけど僕の地元は富山県で！ございます
僕ですね！今回
カタール富山の試合を盛り上げるために呼んでいただきまして！
今回こんな感じでピッチに立たせいただきました！
ほんとにありがとうございます！
あのねぇ！（謎の顔）
サッカーの選手以外でビッチに立つことって凄い大変なんですよ！
ほんとにすごい貴重な経験をさせて頂いてほんとにありがとうございました
一瞬でもあの場所に立てたことが僕すごいうれしかったです
んでそのあとにですね実際に僕試合観戦したんですけども
めちゃくちゃ面白かったです！スゲー惜しいシーンが多くて
試合途中鳥肌立ちましたね！鳥肌がたちました
あわよくば試合に出たい（願い）
試合には出れません（願い粉砕）
というわけで、試合自体すごい楽しくてほんとに満足しました
これですね！
ハーフタイムに、ぼくがステージに立ってマイクでしゃべるんですけど
まあ、見ててくださいよ
こっからだぜ
185センチ（めっちゃ小さい声で）
声小さいよ俺ェ！
声小さいよ！
僕、コミュ障なんで...本当になんかこう言う場所に立ってもこういうつまんない事しか言えないんですけど！
頑張りました... そう、前半 0-0 だったんですけど
惜しかったんすよ！ほんとに惜しかった！
おお！これは面白いの来ますよ
ふつうだぁぁぁ！
いたって普通だ！
ありがとうございます！ほんとに
会場に来てくださったみなさん本当にありがとうございました！
試合は０－０で同点だったんですけども、めちゃくちゃ楽しかったです
なんかこういう形で地元のね、なにか盛り上げることに参加できてとても僕はうれしかったです
またね、機会があれば、こういう感じで地元を盛り上げられればいいなと思っております！
来てくださった皆様、カターレ富山の皆様本当にありがとうございました！
（例のエンディング）